there's various difficulties to working
and filming news in Gaza the first the
obvious one is security and danger Gaza
is one big frontline
there's shells dropping out of the sky
on a regular basis this tank parked up
around the borders so you know you're
operating within a within dangerous area
where things could go wrong and you can
get injured
well you're wearing a flak jacket you're
wearing a helmet which are heavy it's 30
plus degrees you have a camera the
weighs in excess of 10 kilos so you know
getting in now the car is it's hard work
running around chasing stuff it's hard
work I have to be aware of and I have a
sensibility towards the cultural
differences if you get that wrong people
get very angry and they'll make that
very clear to you there's some things I
could film but I choose not to because I
know they're never going to be seen
they're too appalling
[Music]
the most emotional shots are obviously
of people there's a young child who'd
been injured and quite badly and as he
went I saw at the corner of my eye his
mother was sitting there watching for
the go and so we got to see his mother
sort of sitting there watching her child
leave to go to the operating theatre and
that's you know it's it's it stays with
you seeing the kid disappear through the
door and the mother sitting there I
think a little you know I don't know
what happens next
we found this family whose three-story
house has been largely destroyed and we
actually went up onto the third floor to
interview the husband and wife and the
shot we got shows in the background this
sort of what looks like a corridor has
been ripped through this neighborhood
and the lady is standing there we're up
high and the elevation works and just
it's just utter destruction behind her
it was a shot that reminded me of the
sort of things I'd seen as a kid of her
Oshima where entire city force of the
living in the particular angle in the
particular framing lent itself to that
idea of just utter destruction the shot
that I got that gives you some idea of
the destructive power of some of these
shells the landing
you can actually see the camera wobbling
although that landed a good couple
hundred meters away from the hotel the
blast is such that the camera wobbled I
think anyone coming here would be
affected by the things you see
particularly injured and killed having
two children of my own obviously adds
another dimension to that you know when
I see injured and their children you
know sometimes I do think well my
goodness like that could be my son that
could be my daughter but the point
you're actually filming and the the
viewfinder is to your eye I find that I
tend to sort of disassociate myself from
others around me and concentrate on
doing the best job I can on a technical
level as soon as the camera comes off
your shoulder though you're surrounded
by that story again by those people by
their relatives by their destroyed house
and you have to re-engage you can't you
can't operate here just as a sort of
machine just picking up shots you have
to engage with it